meanwhile green arrow says you were you
never I never knew you can't princess
I'm just happy to see you Ali it's been
too long far too long says the Martian
Manhunter to which Oliver Queen says you
ain't gonna try to kiss me - are you
Marvin no but with your permission
Oliver I'd like to take a quick scan of
your mind know if now wrong voice no
offense John but I don't want you
swimming around in my head
understood I merely felt that with some
questions we all had that could be
delivered answered quickly by an
overview of your thoughts and memories
after the big ladies greeting it doesn't
take a telepath to figure out what's on
my mind if you catch my drift
[Music]
who are a little a little racy don't you
think anyway I'm afraid I do oh yes I do
so who the hell are you kid
come on Olli that's mr. Queen to you jr.
uh sorry it's me mr. queen while he was
raw his friends holy cats look at the
size of you come here boy
he puts flat-screen outputs at a flash
in a headlock man you youngsters grow up
quick how's Roy I haven't been able to
get in touch with him but I just figured
he was on a mission with you and the
other kids what are you calling
yourselves again Junior Justice League
Junior you mean the Teen Titans cute as
a button
you tell Roy to check in with his old
man as soon as you can
he's staying off the horse isn't he Roy
who's speedy the Green Arrow's sidekick
at one point very famous issue of DC
Comics revealed the heroin habit yeah
crazy far as I know sir
good it was a close call there for a
little bit but I knew the kid would pull
through so once again this is Oliver
Queen
talking weird to all the current Justice
League like these are all old references
nothing new but Oliver is looking out at
the moon base through the window and he
says would you look at that view I can
appreciate it I'm a little better now
that I'm not throwing up my guts space
the final frontier
ooh that's creepy Wonder Woman up here
Arthur he's behaving strangely Martian
Manhunter to say the least
what are the points he seems to think
it's about Aquaman it's about ten years
ago yeah what gives no clue
he's been acting like this since I found
him tonight it's like he's the old Ollie
and I mean the old ollie
but he actually looks a bit younger than
what I saw him back the last time when
he killed Hey No
hey stroke tonight going between
impressions so fast
where's how anyway and Justice League is
silent because first time always asked
about how Jordan and they all know that
Hal is long gone and they're best
friends Ollie inhales yeah what's with
the looks what I say and wonder woman
says Allie hell hasn't been around here
in quite a while in fact Hales
and then the Man of Steel shows up on
the moon base and says sorry of lead so
idiot tried to blow up the dregs of
metropolis rail will one day great
Caesar's ghost
[Music]
you
[Music]